in 1984 French philosopher Jacques
derida defined the nuclear war as a
fabulously textual reality about which
one can only talk and write about
because it has not yet and in a sense
cannot ever take place since if it did
there would be no place remaining clear
and concise in the common imagination
but also in practice there is only one
way to attempt to escape the disastrous
effects of a nuclear detonation holding
up in a fallout shelter a bunker is
nothing more than an underground shelter
that in a wartime context is exploited
to protect armaments resources and
military personnel this was true at
least until August 1945 when the word
verified the existence of a weapon
capable of Exterminating the human race
the atomic bomb according to American
Professor David Pike it was precisely
the cold war with which the danger of a
global nuclear Holocaust was Associated
that gave rise to the so-called bunker
fantasy that is the widespread belief
that bomb shelters are necessary for the
safety of mankind well someone has taken
this concept literally we are talking
about Switzerland the most bunkered
country in the world with its about 370
000 private Fallout shelters plus nine
thousand public ones intended for those
who don't have the budget to install
them in their own homes on paper
Switzerland is able to protect as many
as 9 million people from radiation for
more than 100 percent of its entire
population impressive huh but how did it
happen it all starts with a pre-cold war
bunker fantasy we are at the beginning
of the second world war France has been
defeated by the Third Reich which Towers
in the north and as a next Austria to
the south on the other hand is fascist
Italy although Switzerland declare the
neutrality Rising border tensions
prompted the authorities to prepare for
a fight on July 25 1940 General Harry
gizan suggested making the Alps
Switzerland's natural barrier the
largest Fortress in Europe the plan is
as follows a abandoned the northern and
southern borders as well as the center
of the country to allow the Army to hold
up in a network of military shelters
built into the rocks in fact the
so-called National without strategy also
known as the Schweitzer edui or
eduinacional had been nagging at the
minds of the Swiss government since the
1880s and the second world war only
served as a fuse for the project to be
carried out visual Pine fortification
consisted of three main bastions The
Goddard SE Maurice and sargans complexes
overseeing 70 other mountain citadels
and 10 000 bunkers capable of housing
hundreds of men each protected by
armored doors and stocked with food
weapons and ammunition according to an
estimate reported by the New York Times
in 1999 the redoubt caused Switzerland
10 billion dollars judged in retrospect
this strategy would be considered yes a
huge deterrent designed to discourage
axis forces from invading the Alps but
also an absurd idea in fact reducing the
country in the view of the Swiss
generals meant to sacrificing the
central plains where the vast majority
of the population lived in short it was
a calculation based on the survival of
the Armed Forces alone yet the obsession
of the Fortress between the Alps would
survive in a different form after the
second world war in the presence of a
far more deadly threat than Air Raids
and tank advances namely the atomic bomb
the Swiss public became increasingly
aware of the need to protect itself from
All Out War it wasn't only the Iron
Curtain that haunted Swiss military
strategists but the very real risk that
the Cold War could soon hit up as early
as the Korean War of
1950-1953 the Swiss Federal Council or
the seven member directorate that
performs the functions of both
government and head of state ruled that
every newly constructed building should
be equipped with an air raid shelter
then in 1956 the Suez Crisis prompted
the federal Council to raise a civil
defense to the status of a
constitutional right and the ultimate
responsibility of State authorities that
said defense defines a constitutional
protection in Article 2 in the part that
states that the Confederation safeguards
the security of the country but two
additional historical contingencies
would prompt the Swiss government to
apply drastic measures in preparation
for a global conflict that seemed
inevitable at the time the building of
the Berlin Wall in 1961 and the Cuba
Missile Crisis in October 1962. not
surprisingly also in 1962 the Swiss
Parliament created a federal office for
civil protection abbreviated to focp
still in existence today whose tasks are
to inform and alert citizens in case of
danger and coordinate possible rescue
operations in October 1963 by unanimous
vote of both houses of Parliament the
federal act on civil defense
construction was passed this provided
for the installation of public Fallout
Bankers in every every settlement with
more than one thousand inhabitants and
not only that under article 46 all
property owners were to construct and
keep their own bomb shelter this was a
rather ambitious provision but it was
dictated by well-established ideological
reasons according to historian Sylvia
bergerzaudin geistige Landes
vertardigung that is the national
intellectual defense implied that
Bankers had to protect all fundamentals
with values federalism Freedom
Independence and neutrality at the same
time however it was the latter that was
sacrificed although Switzerland never
became a NATO member by the dawn of the
1960s the Swiss Federal Council clearly
recognized who the enemy was and that
was communism a year before the
parliament in Burn enacted the federal
law the focp was given a council of 10
experts to figure out how to build
Bankers that would protect people not
only from a nuclear blast but also from
the resulting radiation yes no one one
actually knew how to make one at the
time the only theoretical compendium
available in the west about the atomic
bomb was the book the effects of nuclear
weapons written by physicists Samuel
Gladstone published by the US government
in 1957 and based on experiments
conducted by the Pentagon in Nevada and
the bikiniatul in July 1963 the Swiss
focbs Board of experts invited a number
of us and West German researchers to the
Swiss Federal Institute of Technology in
Zurich to design in cooperation with
Washington a working prototype of a
Fallout bunker there and then the
conference turned out to be a failure
yet in October the Swiss Parliament
would still pass the federal act on
civil defense construction this wasn't a
reckless move in fact during the Zurich
conference the director of The Swiss
Federal Institute of Technology military
engineer Ernest Basler came into contact
with the naval radiological defense
laboratory in San Francisco Stanford
University and MIT in Cambridge thanks
to these connections between 1964 and
1970 dozens of Swiss scientists traveled
to the United States gained access to
their Technologies and once back home
contributed their knowledge to what we
might call a veritable shelter boom
within just six years the number of
private Fallout Bankers in Switzerland
reached 100
000 capable of protecting about to 50
percent of the population an astonishing
achievement considering that the United
States itself has never been able to
implement a structural program to spread
the underground with Bankers it may seem
like nonsense to you but the success and
speed of the Swiss shelters lies in not
having conducted experiments Basler and
the a4cb's board of experts had to act
quickly to fulfill the provisions of the
1963 construction act while trying to
keep costs down with the world war
considered imminent there was no time
for testing so scientists put together
all the data they had come collected on
the effects of a nuclear explosion to
design cost benefit optimal
countermeasures plants walls doors
floors and ventilation systems were
designed according to the following
calculation with an estimated investment
of 1000 Swiss Francs per person
Switzerland could have bunkers capable
of saving from an atomic detonation 90
percent of all those who took shelter in
them the culmination of bunkering
occurred starting in 1971 when the
federal act on civil protection was
extended to Old settlements each private
shelter would be 70 percent publicly
funded if one were to point to the
greatest work of the entire
fortification process in the swisscon
Federation one couldn't fail to mention
the Sonnenberg tunnel opened in 1976 in
Lucerne hidden underneath the playground
one of the world's largest civilian
Bankers cost about 40 million francs was
designed to extend along three
kilometers of tunnels located on the
highway linking Basel to Lugano and to
accommodate about 20 000 people the
banker is a seven story building
stretching downwards and in the minds of
the focp would have required about 700
employees to run its beds command
station Hospital kitchen laundry and
prison in short a real Vault built by
voltec it's just too bad that right now
it's not as massive as planned in 1987 a
year after the charleville accident the
authorities conducted a general test to
evaluate the operation of the tunnel and
realized that the known feasibility of
the initial plan in fact it would never
have been possible to cram such a large
number of human beings into such a small
place in addition getting beds through
inside the narrow corridors would have
been a difficult task on par with
handling a telecommunications in the
absence of radio contact last but not
least some of the doors that were
supposed to seal the tunnels seem to
encounter problems in closing in 2006
the housing capacity of the Sonnenberg
Banker was downsized and its estimate 80
that it can currently accommodate 2 000
people in case of need there is another
problem however according to guide Zora
Shelbert this bunker can certainly come
in handy in case of natural disasters
such as landslides or earthquakes but
not in case of a nuclear explosion after
all the shelter is meant to serve as a
base of support for only a few weeks a
time frame too short for the radiation
outside to thin out at present the main
function performed by the tunnel is as a
tourist attraction and in recent decades
hundreds of unused Bankers some dating
back to the 1940s have been converted
into museums architectural Works
warehouses mushroom Farms hotels and
data centers and even migrant shelters
and in auspicious end you might say but
certainly dictated by the changing
geopolitical environment although
between 1982 and 1983 the Swiss
government had invested 28 dollars per
capita in the defense Sector 10 more
than the entire Soviet Union the threats
of the Cold War and with it the fear of
atomic attack soon vanished from 1989
the rate of a shelter construction
declined but not the debate over the
nation's thought of Defense during the
1980s the Swiss Parliament began to show
its first doubts about fortifying the
country and the pacifist ideology
critical of the militaristic policies
pursued by the federal government in
previous decades became prevalent among
the intellectuals of the time Swiss
journalist Jean Gabriel zuferai summed
them up in 1989 with the term hedgehog
syndrome then the 1990s passed and the
attack on the Twin Towers on September
11 2001 generated the tremendous
insecurity throughout the West when in
2005 Congressman Pierre curler proposed
to abolish the requirement to build the
bunkers adjacent to private homes to
avoid the necessarily increasing the
cost of real estate the federal Council
decided that the shelters were still
useful in defending the population from
terrorist attacks the issue was ignited
in March 2011 following the Fukushima
nuclear disaster however during this
time as Swiss authorities have gradually
relaxed the penalties for violating the
federal law on civil protection
according to a new regulation that came
into effect in 2012 and was confirmed in
2022 only buildings with 38 or more
rooms will have to have a fallout
shelter if it's impossible for technical
reasons to build one an annual
replacement fee of 800 Swiss Francs
about 895 dollars at today's exchange
rate will have to be paid to the state
the same fee is paid by all other
property owners who don't want to make a
home shelter to guarantee them a place
in a public bunker the latter however
must be located in the proximity of
homes that is a distance that can be
walked in half an hour according to
current regulations a banker must be
built according to the technical
instructions issued by the Federal
Department of Defense in 2017 which
indicate materials measures and
maintenance activities to before
followed for every facility built within
the structures from security doors to
kitchens from ventilation and
communication systems to toilets and
light bulbs for the past year Russia's
invasion of Ukraine and the feared use
of tactical nuclear weapons has again
alarmed burner and the cantons according
to Stephen Herzog a nuclear weapons
expert working at the Swiss Federal
Institute of Technology in Zurich
Switzerland is currently the country
best prepared for a possible Atomic
conflict not only because of the 370
000 Bankers scattered throughout its
territory but also because of the
excellent level of nuclear and
radiological protection provided by them
the whole of Switzerland then is covered
by more than 7 000 Sirens which are also
activated in case of more localized
disasters such as fires or floods
finally the alert Swiss app available
since 2019 informs the population about
current alerts and was also functional
during the cavity 19 pandemic in short
it would be fair to say that somehow the
straw strategy of readout envisioned in
the late 1800s has survived to the
present day of course it has changed
guises it has become the armor of a
small country squeezed between the Alps
but diplomatically and economically at
the Pinnacle of the international order
such preparation for any kind of
catastrophe is admirable as well as
unmatched at present for any other state
on the face of the Earth Sweden and
Finland the second and third in class in
the bunker League have facilities that
can save only 70 and 62 percent of their
residents respectively some cantons such
as grissoms and Glarus would be able to
shelter 140 percent of their population
this is the result of the federal
government's investment of about 12
billion dollars diluted over 60 years
all this of course doesn't mean that the
world's most anti-atomic nation is safe
from any apocalyptic scenario again
according to Stephen Herzog in the event
of a nuclear escalation of the Ukrainian
conflict there are so many variables at
play including weather conditions
explosive yield the weapons and altitude
of detonations that it's impossible to
determine with certainty whether the
distance to the war zone and the network
of shelters can protect this with people
100 percent but then is it really
possible to survive a nuclear Armageddon
and once the world we are used to living
in is devastated what will be left of us
one thing is certain Those Who come out
to see the stars again had better have
power armor with them you can't know
what threats might be lurking outside
the Vault well and we are down for today
I thank you all for your attention and
we'll see you in the next video ciao